il s'agit du collège albert einstein
home avis clairement l'équipe joe bon
vainqueur 10 pompes et 2016 il est vrai
que le trophée de match d'improvisation
intercollèges restent chez eux
leymen quoi du collège albert einstein
revoient leurs gammes
l'idée aujourd'hui et sur le court
prochain c'est tenter des choses
d'accord tenter des mises en scène
prenez des risques
amusez vous ok on se précisent sur
certains certains sujets comme la on a
vu les balances donc c'est le fait que
yanakis lettre au canada d'autres qui
sont qui sont par terre et inversement
on fait on revoit un peu tout ce qu'on a
travaillé pendant l'année mais en ayant
plus de liberté deux minutes c'est parti
je pense que c'est la diversité des jeux
parce qu'on a je vais assez différent
fait enfin des actes des comédiens fin
des tic au mieux face aux dîmes aider
des élèves de l'équipe donc je pense que
c'est ça qui fait la force
ils ont entre 11 et 14 ans ils partent
comme favoris à quelques jours du
concours ces collégiens et sont d'une
certaine pression
leur coach en toile donne ses derniers
conseils il faut une histoire plus
construite que sa plus importante que ça
des gens vont essayer de les détendre
parce que malgré tout c'est des
événements qui sont hyper impressionnant
pour eux ils sont dans des grandes
salles ya tous leurs copains qui
viennent les voir
donc on essaie de les rassurer en
en les enrichissant
mais c'est en blindant en essayant de
l'inde est ce qu'ils savent déjà faire
plus que deux marches à gravir pour
inscrire un nouveau leur nom sur le
trophée
ils n'ont qu'une idée en tête
[Applaudissements]